There are a lot of subjects
that students learn about from
kindergarten all the way
through college,
that we could teach in some
really interesting ways.
So for example,
let's imagine you doing a unit on the
Amazonian rainforest in biology class.
One way you could teach that material
is by piling all your students on
to an airplane.
Flying them down to
the Amazonian rainforest and
letting them actually learn about it
by catching animals, dissecting them,
watching them in their natural habitat,
learning about them that way.
It would be really interesting and
really authentic, and really engaging,
and completely unfeasible.
We can't load student onto
airplanes like that and
fly them down to a dangerous area just
to learn about how the rainforest works.
But what we can do is bring
them that experience to their
computers through something like
Amazon Trail, which is a game or
a simulation you all
might be familiar with.
So what we can do is we can use
computers to construct simulations of
the kinds of environments or
experiences we want students to have and
let them engage with it that way.
This can be powerful in another
on a number of different ways.
It's very authentic.
It let's them see not only the content we
want them to learn but also potentially
how people researching that content
actually work in their day to day life.
let's them see what is it like to
actually research biology down
in the Amazon?
Or what is it like to
capture marine animals and
investigate them as a marine biologist?
It's also powerful because it can be
very empowering to let students explore
things on their own.
They kind of get to drive their own
learning and drive their investigation
which aligns very nicely with some
other things we've talked about so
far in this class.
So, simulation-based learning is a great
way to bring authentic and engaging
learning experiences to students
through the power of their computers.
So, in this morsel, we're going to talk
about how we can build simulations that
are engaging and authentic for the
material we want to teach the students.